good morning John I lost about your
first case right I want to get to that
but first I wanted to talk about the
fact that I got to interview a scientist
from the Large Hadron Collider I thought
about your first case really we're gonna
do this first I lost about your first
case okay we're going to do this first
and third grade I dated a girl for like
six months I kissed her on the forehead
cheek in hand our friends through a mock
wedding for us in my pool area and she
got cold feet and wouldn't fake marry me
my first actual like germ swapping mouth
kiss was with a girl whose last name was
noob wha but everybody called her dubois
she was a fan of the men folk including
me most expensive casual item of
clothing ever bought in Montana it is
good to be prepared for the winter
seasons in whatever way you can there's
something my pocket money money from
last winter money six bucks I didn't
know I had it also there were some
receipts let's see what I bought last
year beer that's all the only thing on
this receipt is that six of Miller
highlight Mick and show my dues get paid
first job you ever once it as a kid like
around 85% of my elementary school class
I wanted to be an oceanographer I wrote
a haiku about it and it was so good that
I remember it to this very day
oceanographer that is what I want to be
oceanographer tell us about your group
of school friends we called ourselves
the posse and there were five of us and
I was the only boy well that explains a
lot
shut up we passed notes in school and we
renamed all the days of the week and we
would sit around and listen to Hanson
and the sounds like it's middle school
but it wasn't it was senior year in high
schools for girls wedgie Kelly Amanda in
Casey remains some of my best friends in
the world and I'm very lucky to have had
them what would you name your kids well
I could tell you exactly what I'm not
going to name my kids a hunter olive
Forest lime asparagus of my last name's
green cute names are cute for like 0.1%
of a child's like who do you want to
answer the survey next I would like all
of my ex-girlfriends to answer this
because I want to know if I was their
first kiss I have a feeling that I was
no one's first kiss which is kind of sad
to me I know most virtually like
hatchet-face from crybaby to answer this
because I don't I'm just curious how
she's doing
in addition to interviewing myself just
now I alluded earlier to the fact that
today I interviewed Joe Incandela one of
the top scientists at the Large Hadron
Collider Joe is pretty famous in the
world of particle physics he helped
discover the top quark I got to talk to
him for a half an hour this morning and
you know why because of you people no
one would ever talk to me about awesome
things if it weren't for you so thank
you it was pretty much like the coolest
thing that happened to me like ever that
should be a new segment on vlogbrothers
the coolest thing that happen to me like
ever so John I talked a lot a lot of
things consider like like me
occasionally thinking in my office so
many heroes of our last 10 15 years the
crisis what if we don't find anything
Peter it doesn't work that way because
we know there has to be something that's
got to give if we find it then we have
to study it and the details when he tell
us a lot about where to look next and if
we don't find it although it will be our
new finalists for funding agencies it's
a much more exciting situation where you
get to you get to make up your own part
because I have your name on them one
thing we did talk about is that neutrino
that supposedly went faster than light
and now risen I haven't talked about
those people that asked me about this on
Twitter is because I'm reserving
judgment I just have a hard time you
know sort of coming to terms the fact
that I might live in a world where
matter can travel faster than speed of
light makes me want to make this noise
yeah
that actually with probably the most
articulate thing I've ever said about
particle physics in my life John I will
see you on ones day
what's holding you from falling to the
center of the earth right now my chair